we want to get you more on a new CBS
poll that shows while most Americans do
not think the Trump administration was
prepared for the corona virus pandemic
53% do approve of the way the president
is handling it although that is changing
the president now appears to be backing
away from recommendations that people
should stay home over a long period of
time because of his concerns about the
effects on the economy if it were up to
the doctors they say let's keep it shut
down let's shut down the entire world
because again you're up to almost 150
countries so let's shut down the entire
world and when we shut it down that
would be wonderful let's keep it shut
for a couple of years you know I can't
do that that's why I talked about the
cure being worse than the problem we
can't have the Cure be worse than the
problem so we should point out that CBS
News has not heard any recommendation
from any doctor about a multi-year
shutdown although certainly a short-term
shutdown is on the way
Paula Reid is at the White House for us
Paula good morning so what are the
president's comments suggest about what
he's likely to do next
oh good morning Tony the president
appears to be laying the groundwork to
reopen sectors of the economy and send
people back to work
president said on Monday he will make an
announcement about whether to ease the
current restrictions but at a nearly two
hour briefing last night the president
said it will be a matter of weeks not
months before he tries to reopen the
country but asked if he was risking
lives by doing this the president
insisted he believes the dire economic
conditions could lead to suicides which
he claims would result in an even higher
death toll though many medical experts
disagree with that assessment
the president said going forward he will
consult with medical experts on this
effort along with others but when
pressed he would not say who else he is
talking to to get advice about how to
guide the country through this
unprecedented economic turmoil
now dr. Anthony Falchi is the one who
many Americans say they really want to
hear from when it comes to coronavirus
he was not at last night's briefing the
president was asked about this and the
president insisted he believes the
doctor is a very good man but said the
world renowned infectious disease expert
was not at the briefing because they
were not discussing his area of
tee's Gail a lot of people wondering
where was dr. Falchi yesterday thank you
very much Paula